wieder läuft die alte ist die beste
unterstützung die ich hier hatte das
gebäude gegen die wand alter charlie du
blöder pizza ich verrate euch alle ich
verrate euch alle hier blöden ich mach
einfach die tür auf
niemand wird mich daran hindern hey hey
leute und herzlich willkommen zu einer
runde vampires setzt wo ich euch jetzt
wieder die besten szenen rausch leider
werde ich habe das letzte mal schon mit
happiness gemacht was er sehr gut bei
euch an comedy allem er wollte bzw
die meisten deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht dass das ganze jetzt mal mit
vampires set mache und das ist ein spiel
das auf high pixel
da geht's halt darum dass zwei leute
werden bestimmt die vampire sind und die
müssen halt die anderen leute die hier
so die überlebenden sind mehr oder
weniger müssen nicht zu papier machen
wir die schlagen beißen töten et cetera
und ich würde sagen es geht los
oh mein gott oh mein gott ich bin ob ich
bin in der lobby und da hat einer
geschrieben oh hi
was wohl mein gott es geht los also wir
sind jetzt in dieser komischen web hier
drin und müssen jetzt mehr oder weniger
von den ganzen anderen vampiren hier
rumlaufen ich bin kein vampir sondern
ich bin einer von den vielen hier und
ich bleiben einfach bei denen du stehst
nur um du stehst darum beweg dich ja
komm wir machen team von bob hartley und
wirtsleute ich glaube mein ziel wird
sein dieses mal einfach superman zu
verfolgen bis er sich irgendwie des
todes aufrichtig verfolgt ihn jetzt
einfach reichere ich hoffe zombies also
ich bin grade des todes betrunken nein
muss man zappt man hin muss da hin
da bei jungs machen wir gruppenkuscheln
laptop zu [ __ ] hallo du oh mein gott
oh mein gott jürgen bogs sichere boxee
box oder ist irgendwie irre
ich habe eine nachricht bekommen rote
haare hast du als scherz gemeint was her
ich geb doch meinen holzschwerter flanke
für zurückgeht zurück weil ich boxen und
ich blocke wer ist der ball wieder
irgendwas komisch gelingt ach ich hab
das kreuz bekommt auch so her locker
easy alte ich verrate euch alle ich
verrate euch alle hier blöden ich mach
einfach die tür auf hoffe niemand
wirklich daran hindern
hey du bist der du willst auch ein paar
leute hier kann ich krieg denke dass
noch ein blöder pizza doch gekillt habe
ich hab keine rüstung hat geburtstag
also es wird zeit zu zweit zwei zu zweit
mit zeit zu zeit immer schwieriger hier
drin weil die halt immer stärker werden
die christen und blabla
jetzt habe ich denn ich habe helfer sich
darin kills zu rings double coin
speakern auf wechsel
pixel sache halt pixel das doch
irgendwie von komischen meinen
kopfhörern weil ich irgendwie ich höre
mich zwar aber nur so halb deswegen
verspreche ich mich bestimmt voll auf
das vorland weil ich gar keine zombies
kommt mir herr jungs dann hab ich alles
so ein bisschen euro-länder ab ich hoffs
länder oder keiner bisher wo ich möchte
doch nur spiegel mit euch aber ich bin
des todes betrunken heute jetzt nicht
mehr kannte mein vater hoch an der ruf
des haus was du deshalb jetzt jetzt darf
kein zombie com und da ist ein zombie
ich muss mal die anderen finden alter
hier sind welchen sport bei dir
nein ich gehe es wieder in der runde
hier eine typische runde immer ich war
komisch
das schwert des todes
ab
ich mache jetzt 36 lieben die musik
fehlt nur noch ein treffen irgendwo ob
das war eine fackel die hundehalter du
und du scheiß vampir alter ich muss ich
muss weg dass der vampir da ist hat
seine spuren
seine spuren dem will ich mit schnappen
muster denn ok der vp hat ihn geholt
oder nehmen keine ahnung schreibt mir
meine kommt darum kämpfen die spielleute
ich spiele das und ich laufen rum und
ich kann darf ja gar nicht
sls ist unentschieden
50 prozent der gespendeten coins wurden
rief an dat ok cool unentschieden
ich werde natürlich nicht der barbar
wenn ich nicht noch eine runde
dranhängen würde der träger für die
fragen es geht jeden moment laut 10 9 8
7 6 5 4 3
okay wir sind drin
hey komm mal dass ein könig dass jetzt
ein neuer king hier die wand iwankow
ivan pavic voller sterne waren dadurch
stellen
the wall als alter das ist geil
du bist dann überleben der +25 gold ich
habe gold dafür bekommen dass ich
überleben da bin wo ich etwas kann aber
okay wir jetzt schon zwei vampire dass
es mehr als im kompletten letzten spiel
gab
ich höre hier etwas das papier das
papier dass wir das papier ich hab' ich
bin tot
okay erzählte die ansicht mal als vampir
und zwar muss ich jetzt hier so okay ich
habe jemanden getötet spa butler haben
ich nehme das jetzt ist er meiner ordner
galt der die füße ok ich nenne ich
charlie
nein da kam ein blitz auf charlie
charlie charlie blöd schauen sie stellt
ihr nur um der macht einfach nix er
steht einfach
er steht einfach nur um charlie
westermann alte stammgäste wandelnden
wieder neue läuft die alte ist die beste
unterstützung die ich hier hat er doch
einfach unser gebäude rein guckt gegen
die wand alte charlie du blöder besser
kann gar nix junge gar nix
im haus drin aber wichtiger boxe nicht
so gut wie tot
wenn ich dachte der zukunft hat die sind
hier man man man guckt jetzt einfach mal
bei dieser komischen pyramide hier jetzt
einfach mal bei dieser komischen bochum
mutig alter okay es gibt noch zweite
wahl pass wenn ich davon ein finder bin
ich dabei
ich dachte jetzt so ich könnte so
richtig cool einfinden und dass man
sogar einen schnellen aber ich finde
einfach keinen ich weiß nicht wo die
sich verstecken
ok wenn du fünf ist gespannt und es gibt
nur noch einen überlebenden
das wird heftig für geben aber ich
möchte töten
haunted forest and apparel okay ich bin
dran ich bin sollen bertelsmann wo kann
er denn sein das kann design ist jetzt
gewinnt oder dass er so viele runden
durchhält
vor allem der versteckt sich bestimmt
einfach irgendwo komme ich motiviert mal
ein bisschen unser team gewonnen
schön dich gar nicht motivieren aber ich
werde nicht der ba ba ba ba wenn ich
ohne runde dranhängen würde
die schilder sind weg crazy daisy los
geht's um eine neue map alter ich bin
ein vampir direkt von anfang an alter
ich bin der einzige mit den anderen
schillig alter lukas vampir von anfang
an das war keine gute entscheidung
spielen können
ok ok kommen wir sterben sterben wir
sterben sterben ja man erst kommt ich
glaube ich kaufe mir wieder so einen
komischen zombie aber diesmal nicht den
direkt vor den anderen los komm kleiner
aniello
los aller drauf auf den alle drauf
worten ja ja die box wirst du alter
geboxt wirst du sterben wirst du ja erst
tor das ist mein zweiter kill soll
kommen es geht auf die nächsten kleiner
zombie charlie charlie los charlie
begreift langsam wie sie das spiel hier
läuft ja charlie los los los dass der
dritte jahres ist der dritte halt so
stolz auf meinen kleinen charlie bekommt
du bist als du bist als nächste seite
notwendig so haken gröger töten
los los los los werder bleibt einfach
stehen ist der tote lag des todes aber
erst tut alter november jetzt machen
randale alter wenn das rebellieren
scheint meine kommentare vampires
rebellieren mit mutter conny ist kein
nun connys pro ohne witz alter ich
bringe alle ums todes okay das sind auch
sieben leute in einem gebäude was
natürlich über zwei kraft ist charlie
charlie des wahnsinns da besser wenig
betrunken könnte nämlich noch welchem
ein mensch ich finde keine mehr
es gibt noch 22 was nur noch ich hab 59
blut heißt what they survivor okay okay
okay da bringt mich jetzt da hin dass
derzeit nur dahin dass jeder ist okay es
gibt nur noch ein
du musst doch dann hier irgendwie sein
das hat sich geräumt da ist einer der
besten adressen versichert die abstieg
stirbt stirbt stickstoff die ft ft ft ft
nein das ist aber auch auf jeden fall
sehr sehr männlich wenn man sich einfach
im boden eck gestellt ich glaube da muss
sich charly man holen haben gewonnen
ja ich hab die wember ist auf den sieg
gebracht ja so leute das war's mal
wieder mit einer fahne gaming onetouch
mehr oder weniger mit den besten zehn
eine gameplays rausgeschnitten hab ich
ja schon mal mit happy meals gemacht
dass verlinkt ich euch dass verleger ich
euch auch in der beschreibung deswegen
wenn es euch gefallen und ihr mehr von
so was haben wollt dann packen wir 5000
leipzig weiß es nicht schafft die
community das deswegen 5000 likes und
dann mache ich eventuell nummer so was
wenn ihr mir dadurch zeigt dass ich mehr
davon machen sie eine stadtbahn kommt
haare
vampires rebellieren mit dem hashtag von
natürlich und dann sehen wir uns in der
nächsten folge wieder schauer und
übrigens morgen kommt so eine geile im
atrium morgen um 14.30 kommt die geilste
mio die ich hier aufgenommen
hammergeil eine superlange vorbereitung
bestreitet das rot im kalender an und
das wird auf jeden fall hammergeil und